hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game that just ended from the
world rapid Team Championship in
Dusseldorf it is Petersville versus
Daniel dubov and it's quite quite an
attacking game you guys will enjoy this
when you guys have requested more do
both games but also you guys have
requested a more swedler game so I
thought uh let's uh you know uh handle
it by showing a nice filler versus Doom
of games so let's check it out I'm not
gonna spoil anything uh silver uh Peter
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for that 80 opening
we have D5 by Daniel and now Pawn to G3
sorry about that I thought I
covered that before uh G3 he goes for
the king's Indian attack we have G6 and
pawn to D4 we have Knight to F6 and now
Pawn to C4 uh we have C6 and now uh
usually uh Bishop to G2 is the common
move here but we have Queen to A4 and
this move has only been played a handful
of times uh the characters on c for
Queen captures on C4 and now Bishop to
G7 so okay a few more moves will be
played and players will transpose into
known territory castles castles and pawn
to B5 now what's interesting about the
spawn to B5 move is that the doob have
already had this position
uh he had it with black uh he uh faced
it against the Lebon Aruna and Hikaru
Nakamura but switler also had it with
black he played it against Shakir
mamiyarov and all three games I believe
ended in a draw so both of them are very
much familiar with this position I
believe we have Queen to C3 uh and now
Bishop to F5 there is a game where
Knight the E4 was played Just continuing
the attack on the queen where A5 was
played uh also a queen to B6 move is
known uh but here we have just um uh
Bishop the five and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
okay Rook to D1 makes sense to align The
Rook nicely with the queen we have Pawn
the A5 of course dubo wants to push B4
we have Queen back the ones we'll learn
now frees up the C3 Square for his
Knight and he wants the strike in the
center with Ponte E4 and the bishop the
C2 dubov is being annoying with the
bishop says all right you have to move
your Rook to a less uh less perfect
square than D1 it's okay Rook to D2 for
the moment hindering the development of
the dark Square Bishop Bishop goes back
to F5 and now Knight to C3 and now he's
ready to execute Pawn to E4 so dubov
stops it by playing Knight to E4 himself
with Rogue back to D1 also the Knight is
The Rook is attacked now Rogue back to
D1 and now Knight captures on C3
probably uh trying to be
um you know uh very much annoying with
the bishop if Peter captures with the
pawn then he's gonna play Bishop to C2
right back so Peter captures with the
queen and now Pawn to B4 attacking the
White Queen and yes it is the strongest
move in the position Queen to B3 and now
comes Knight to D7 now it's time to
develop uh all the other pieces we have
Knight to D7 and now Bishop to G5
putting pressure on this E7 pawn and
dubov just moves it Queen to B6 now
Bishop captures an E7 is not really a
threat if you capture this then a rook
attacks Bishop wants the bishop moves
you lose the EQ Pawn so it's basically a
trade of the e-pawns so Rook 8 to C1 and
now we have Pawn to A4 winning more
Square here on the queen side and we
have Queen back the E3 and now Bishop to
E6 putting pressure on this A2 Pawn so
Pawn to A3 and now double again being
well harassing that Rook on D1 Bishop to
B3 will Rook to D2 and now okay you
could play uh something but first he
wants to take care of the tension on the
queen side he plays B captures on A3 big
captures and only now Rook after E8 uh
we have Bishop to H6 appear continues
with his plan he wants to trade of the
dark Square Bishops and Bishop to F6 we
have Queen to F4 and now dubov tries to
figure out a plan you could go for some
like Rook 8 to d8 but he goes for Knight
f8 he wants to play Knight to E6 and
chase away the black queen from such an
active square but uh Peter beats him to
the punch he plays Knight to E5 and okay
how does this change anything well
Knights the D6 attacks the queen but
also Knights the D7 attacks the queen on
B6 now the question is can you trade
Queens here
uh you you cannot if you play Knight
captures on F4 uh Knight captures and V6
comes with an attack on the rook and now
there's just no good move you could play
if you play Rook 8 to B8 seems like
you're doing fine you say okay you
capture my Rook uh my knight I'm gonna
capture your knight but all of a sudden
Bishop captures and C6 happens and this
bishop was crucial there
um uh dubo would have used it to play
Knight captures on G2 so he doesn't have
to worry about spending an extra attempt
at to get rid of the knight from F4 and
now okay you're just a dead lost here
your Rook is hanging if you play Rook
somewhere you could play at the d8
Knight to D7 now again attacks The Rook
your knight is still hanging and there's
just no good move to play here rugby to
see it can be played uh and now okay it
does come with a little trigger because
if you capture a capture with an eye
then real captures on D7 you cannot
recapture due to the rook and C1 being
undefended but you can just eliminate
the bishop with check and then after he
captures you just pick up the Knight and
F4 for free that's pretty much it
there's no way to pile up on the bishop
on C6 uh so instead after 9 37 dubov
just goes back Queen 38 and now uh Peter
eliminates the the bishop wit check
Knight captures we have Pawn captures
and now Queen to H4 and okay and now uh
the pawn structure is uh a bit messed up
here uh but that's not uh uh you know
everything that he has to worry about
Bishop captures and C6 is the threat the
bishop and Rook are attacking it so he
has to stop it somehow but uh how could
he do it can can he play something like
Bishop to D5 he can but then E4 is is an
automatic so instead we have rooked the
C8 uh double decides to give up the C6
pawn and uh Peter captures it Rook
captures on C6 and here there is uh one
a very tricky Line dubo is now just down
a piece and he will have to suffer uh do
uh to Peter having the pass d-pawn but
there is one a very specific line that
allows do both the basically draw by
force uh and uh he doesn't play it I'm
just gonna show it to you as it's a
beautiful line and it starts with phone
to G5 sort of attacking the queen and
straight branding the dark Square Bishop
on H6 and okay where do you go with the
queen if you go to E4 then you go under
the mask of The Rook then some Knights
therefore ideas are happening uh so best
bet would be to go Queen G4 and now
Queen to A5 also the rook and D2 is now
undefended as we've locked out the
bishop uh on H6 uh and after Rook
captures on Z8 then Rook captures uh
what do you play you cannot move the
Rook just anywhere the bishop covers the
D1 Square also Rook the C1 check will be
deadly if it lands so your only hope is
to actually give up that Rook with
Bishop to E4 and he would we would get a
force to draw the queen captures on D2
now Queen F5 threatening Checkmate and
now after a few checks let's say queen
C1 checking to G2 you will have to stop
checkmate with Knight to f8 but now
Queen captures an F6 threatens Checkmate
and now Knight back the E6 defense
against Checkmate Queen F5 Knight f8
Queen F6 Knight to E6 and we would have
a draw by Perpetual so just a you know a
spectacular line I just really wanted to
show this to you but Queen the E7 was
played and now this gives Peter just
enough time to start that pawn up the
board so Pawn to D5 attacks the Knight
and Rook captures on C6 of course you're
now going to move the Knight E captures
uh D captures and C6 and now comes Queen
captures on A3 here dubo is down upon
and if he can grab the A3 Pawn create a
pass Pawn of his own then he's back into
the game but here probably G5 was his
best option and after Queen day for now
uh sorry now you capture on A3 but still
Queen to B1 will be placed a sort of uh
counter that passed a pawn and now
Bishop can be played the E4 or The Rook
can come to D7 this is still a better
position for uh for uh Peter but okay
Queen captures on A3 was played right
away by uh Daniel and now comes Queen
captures on F6 now Peter is a
threatening Checkmate so Queen to C1
with check with Bishop to F1 and now
Queen captures on C6 so the wolf
eliminates the pawn uh now the material
is even and now he's ready to start
pushing his a phone but the problem is
Bishop to H3 now with the thread of
Simply eliminating the Knight which
defends the G7 square and then the
thread is Queen to G7 Checkmate so is
there is there something Peter can do to
avoid this well Queen the C1 with
Cherokee will throw in a few checks of
course Queen to C6 check with Ponte F3
again the thread is uh the exact same
one and now Queen the C7 this is a great
attempt to buy uh Daniel uh because now
if you play Bishop capture then F
characters and the G7 Pawn is defended
and now the a pawn starts marching
forward so instead after Queen to C7 uh
uh Peter finds a brilliant attacking
move one that I have no doubt to do but
would play in this position himself and
that is Rook to D4 now again of course
the Knight cannot capture it will be
Checkmate on G7 and if you just start
advancing the pawn what's the real
threat here well if you start advancing
the pawn not that The Rook is on D4 now
Bishop captures an E6 is a deadly threat
because after F captures an E6 look at
this Rook to F4 with an unstop mate
Queen to f8 will be Checkmate once you
give up the queen captures captures Rook
will deliver Checkmate and there's no
way to avoid this and whatever you play
It's the exact same Checkmate Queen to
f8 will be played whatever move black
makes it's that kind of a position even
if you play dog cave the queen D7 uh you
don't go uh Queen to fade you will first
capture the queen and then deliver Rook
to f8 Checkmate but the idea behind the
Checkmate is the same so instead I have
to Rook to D4 uh dubo tried to avoid
this he played Bishop to C2 trying to be
a little bit tricky uh but still uh
Bishop captures an um here will be very
strong but there's even a stronger move
now and that is of course the one that
Peter plays uh so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for Peter while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on paying zero
attention to what I was saying as I gave
the solution away and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course the best shop captures on E6 so
why does it work now uh well the reason
is of course uh that uh well once F
captures an E6 you will play Rook to C4
this is what dubo this is what Peter
played and it was in this position on
move 39 uh that Daniel dubo resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here now you have to choose you either
uh moved you cannot move the queen from
the seventh rank you get checkmated uh
and if you just move the queen doesn't
really matter where you could play Queen
day seven okay it does look like maybe
you're gonna be able to post some
threads here if Rook captures on C2 is
played uh but the threat now is not Rook
captures on C2 the thread is Rook to see
it with the threat of mating one and
there's no way to avoid that Rook
captures and C8 will be met with Queen
captures and E6 a nice check Fork here
and if you go here then this is just
just a nice meeting one Queen captures
and see it as the bishop covers G7 and
if you don't if you block with the queen
then it's just well the same Checkmate
only in two queen captures on C8 Queen
will block and now Queen captures an f8
so very nicely done by Peter eliminating
dubo like this uh he played a very
natural moves do both tried to work his
magic around Peter but Peter you know
wasn't
um uh interested in in in any any of
that kind of Chess and when he gave him
this opportunity that we've mentioned
after you know this queen to H4 was
played uh he just didn't found this
crucial G5 idea it I mean it's a it's a
brutal line of course you do not find
something like that in Rapid chest but
that's why we show games afterwards they
are played you know on the on the
internet uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoy that if you have any
other game that you've enjoyed from the
second day of the world rapid Team
Championship use hashtag suggestion uh
in the comments and I will definitely go
over them uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Andrew woolly an anonymous person
Grizzly chess festival.org.gg and India
moon for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
any one of the suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day